No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pleasure to introduce the next speaker
and actually the OT speaker for the
afternoon
yeah after that your chest we'll have a
discussion me cha-cha prosky becomes
ante we'll talk about similarity
alignment the missing link between
structural function and algorithms right
thank you very much for having me here
that's always a pleasure so I think
there were enough talks this workshop
already to convince you that with all
the explosion in neuroscience data
acquisition from neuronal population
activity to connect omics there is an
urgent need for a theory that would
explain or account for all this
observations but also relate them to the
computation that the brain carries out
right so what kind of theory could fit
this niche that's what I would like to
address in this talk now these days can
give a talk without mentioning deep
learning so here is a slide comparing
what deep learning networks do and and
the biological neural networks so one
difference is that in most cases the
deep learning networks are used in
supervised setting they trained on huge
label data sets yet in biology labeled
examples are rare and most of the
learning
I think happens in unsupervised setting
with just very few labels involved so
more like maybe a semi-supervised if you
want to push it or reinforcement learn
but not supervise say so that's one
major difference and the other major
difference is that in constructing those
networks computer scientists typically
don't care whether they're biologically
plausible in a sense that they use
learning rules that are known local
meaning that the synaptic weight is
adjusted based on the activity of a lot
of other neurons in the system not just
the two neurons that the synapse
connects which is of course the only
thing that biology would allow in a real
brain just because physically a synapse
has access only to the activity of those
two neurons I can't resist pointing out
that you're right about that problem the
bolsa regime which also has a striped
version is heavier so it's not that it's
not right yeah I'm requiring it yes it's
an important comment about the current
generation that is very efficiently
being put to use but it is it's not a
restriction on being able to do deep
learning right and also both of machine
is can be used in unsupervised mode so
that's not what I'm comparing right
thanks
yeah that's an important that's an
important point well so that's why I'm
not that enthusiastic about using deep
convolutional network as that theory
that connects experiment to computation
even though there is a similarity
between the two okay I made the slide
before Tyler's talk okay so now
now I would say less poorly understood
that I thought
nevertheless my mathematician colleagues
tell me that this kind of similarity is
not a good reason to use this as a model
of that so we would like to come up with
an alternative kind of framework that
would be built by what we call a
normative algorithmic approach okay so
we would like to start with some sort of
computational objective that is
motivated by the computational task that
the brain performs so that's the link to
computation right so we will focus on
object categorization which is what
convolutional networks also do you know
but in unsupervised setting so it would
be clustering in the first part of the
talk and manifold learning or
disentangle in the second part of the
talk once formulating the subjective
mathematically we would like to derive
an online algorithm that optimizes the
subjective what do I mean by an online
algorithm well that's an algorithm which
operates in a biological setting
biologically plausible setting where
data is not available all at once it is
streamed to the brain by sensor organs
one sample at a time and the brain
cannot wait too much before computing
the output so the output has to be
produced on the fly in real time and
without requiring large memory storage
capacity right so you cannot like it's
done in classical but you know machine
learning or statistics algorithm you
cannot load all the data into RAM and
crunch it there that's not a
biologically plausible mode at least not
on the level mechanistic level of
individual neurons and microcircuits
okay that's the level we're addressing
so the goal is to derive an online
algorithm and then to map that algorithm
into a neural network in some sense to
derive a neural network architecture
whose dynamics both neural activity
dynamics and synaptic plasticity will
carry out the steps of the online outage
and what's crucial we will want to
ensure that we are not violating the
biological requirement on the locality
of learning rules that there have been
or until have been accomplished okay so
that's kind of our program and I have to
admit that it's not entirely new you
know even in the 90s people have used
this kind of approach you know one
famous example is of course Bruna's
sparse dictionary learning we are
starting with the objective minimizing
l1 regularized reconstruction error they
derived an online algorithm which
actually does map onto neural network
which in some architectures gives local
learning rules okay so this program has
been also followed by other people but
what we did differently is we started
with a different computational objective
and that allowed us to resolve some
problems that existed with
reconstruction error minimization
approach but also gave some interesting
results that I think is available not
just to understand how the brain works
but in general for machine learning so
what so before I tell you what our
approach is I want to motivate it by
showing you an experimental result that
was obtained by functional MRI in human
in fair term infer temporal cortex this
is a higher visual area and what they
did they basically showed to a subject a
hundred different objects and recorded
neural activity vectors okay where
component each component of vector is
activation of a voxel in fMRI image and
then they computed inner products or
correlations between all pairs of such
vectors between pairs of such vectors
corresponding to all pairs of the
objects and they filled up this
similarity matrix
okay so if the two objects produce
similar activity patterns in IT they're
shown by a blue pixel dissimilar
activity patterns they're shown by red
pixel and immediately you can see this
log diagonal structure which seems to
align with animate and inanimate
categories suggesting that the activity
patterns corresponding to animate
objects are more similar to each other
than animal to inanimate okay what's the
scale is like dark blue like perfect
100% correlation or is this like a
maximum at 30% oh that's a good question
I don't actually remember this data is
taken from series of papers by cricket
score there you know I would say it's
probably well okay here's the way to
answer this question the diagonal right
shows perfect correlation okay so that's
that the color corresponding to one well
it shows do you share the same thing
twice yeah so there is a little bit of a
spread there too I don't remember
exactly how much spread there was but
you know it's pretty high okay
anyhow so this is the similarity matrix
that was measured in 100 so these are
these are animal objects you should put
objects by animate and 40 phase in the
system well there have been there have
been there has been prior knowledge that
the way those objects are presented may
have may have some separation oh no they
just yeah they just ordered it basically
animal this way an inanimate that way
yeah yeah there's no train how do you
measure the similarity of two
so this this is just correlation so this
is just in the product normalized in a
product you can also compute distances
but yeah so so this is the observation
you know some people find it more
surprising than others but what I think
is really amazing is that if you compute
this similarity matrix for different
individuals you will get a very similar
similarity matrix
even though individual activity patterns
in the brains of those individuals that
correspond to the same stimulus could be
very different right because the neurons
between the individuals are not
identifiable there could be even a
different number okay yet the similarity
matrix is invariant and it's so
invariant it's scary
okay because this is a similarity matrix
from a monkey I T okay and it's obtained
not by fMRI if anyone doesn't take this
fMRI evidence seriously but by single
unit electrophysiology okay so this is
similarity computed on activity vectors
where each component is a fire rate of
an individual neuron and I t over monkey
and you get pretty much similar
structure well there are both monkey
faces and human faces I mean I'm sure
when you zoom into the details you will
see differences here but on the animate
and inanimate I think it's it's all
pretty similar okay
so I think this is amazing that
similarity matrices but not activity
patterns are the invariants between
different neural representations of
different individuals since that day to
come out there are some more indication
that this is indeed the case the latest
ones are still unpublished works in the
olfactory system both
in mammals and invertebrates which show
very well that again even though
activity patterns in piriform cortex or
mushroom body may be very different from
individual to individual similarity
matrix is computed for each individual's
are are invariant know the
dimensionality is determined by the data
set the internal dimensionality is of
course very different I don't know I
think it's probably hired here because
they record it from many neurons because
they just you know maybe dozens of
neurons and here there's a there's a
single unit electrode recording to you
and the human fMRI so these are voxels
but I T is not that big I don't know how
many boxes there are okay but I suspect
that here the folded dimensionality is
slightly bigger maybe maybe but they'll
factory so you can argue because this is
not this is fMRI okay you don't know
what happens in those voxels these are
single unit recordings so you combine
from different trials but they'll
factory data that is still unpublished
is comes from calcium imaging so it's a
population activity and it's very hard
to argue with it okay
so this kind of observation makes you
understand why thinking about neural
representation as a representation of
similarities as was pointed out in a
long paper by Shimon Edelman in 98 is a
good idea okay if something is invariant
right that may be something that biology
really cares about so that's kind of a
starting point for us but the question
we addressed is okay so we're going to
use similarity as the neural
representation but the big question is
how do you get that similarity matrix
right because the similar
my matrix is not the same in every
visual area right this is similarity
matrix in IT right and if you are record
activity in v1 and responds to the same
set of objects you of course don't see
the structure because v1 does not care
whether the object is animate or
inanimate it cares about edges and if
the edge statistics is normalized
between animate and inanimate you won't
see much structure so that's exactly
what happened so how does the brain get
aget from this kind of similarity matrix
to that kind of similarity matrix and
what I would like to do is to say okay
if the view neural computation as a
transformation of similarity matrix we
can actually make progress and the
zeroth order way to think about it which
might seem a little bit counterintuitive
given the previous slide is what we call
similarity alignment basically what you
want to do between the inputs and the
outputs of a single layer of a neural
network is to match similar output
similar input activity to similar output
activity okay so it's like
multi-dimensional scaling or manifold
learning you're trying to preserve
distances between nearby stimuli of
course what this doesn't tell you what
you do with the remote stimuli and
that's where the whole game is played
okay and that's why by applying this
transformation multiple times we think
you can get from this similarity matrix
to that similarity matrix
we'll be you know a friendly amendment
yeah I I agree but I think that if I
really follow this line of questioning
we run into the limitations of
unsupervised setting right we have to
say well you can't just like analyze
images and get all the stuff out you
have to think about behavioral goals
right so but we are not going that far
for this talk on the we're staying and
we supervise an unsupervised setting and
which is probably okay to deal with the
first few layers because those
representations will be used for all
different tasks for the figure in the
left yeah yeah using the categories and
clusters and Howell objects they're
using for the figure on the right yeah I
wonder if you something like somewhere
between like edges oh yeah yeah and in
fact I have a plot I'm sorry I don't
have it in this PowerPoint but I have a
slide showing that if you plot
adjuration
similarity then you get a beautiful to
bandit structure just as you would
expect yes
so maybe that I think what I'm trying to
clarify then is that your previous slide
said that you're trying to you you want
to map it put similarity in the input
space dissimilarity in the neural space
but here we're seeing similarity in a
psychological space right so what what I
want to yeah that's that's confusing I'm
sorry I know this problem exists what I
want to talk about is the transformation
taking place in each layer in one layer
only okay I don't have a full answer to
how stacking those layers will get you
from there to here to the psychological
similarities but I think that for a
single layer
you can't think in zeroth order that you
just preserve the distances between
nearby objects okay but we will see why
we think it's likely that this can give
you a psychological similarity towards
the end of the talk but it may not be
clear yes
all right okay so so let's set up some
simple computational problem right since
we're talking about categorization which
deep learning of course does extremely
well we're going to do it and on
supervised setting so in the pixel
intensity space the difference between
animate and inanimate objects in the
simplest case would be just like this
kind of two clouds of data that may
perhaps be linearly separable okay this
doesn't have to be the case the
manifolds can be entangled that's what
we deal will deal with part in part two
but in part one we will just do
unsupervised clustering of this linearly
separable data set okay well you may
think oh what's the big deal right there
are tons of clustering algorithms and
networks and I would argue that actually
none of those exist in algorithms at
least the ones that I know of pass our
requirements for biological plausibility
right so these algorithms are mainstay
of Statistics of course but they are all
offline okay even if you have online
k-means algorithm for example like the
implementations by this neural networks
you may have something that works online
but when you look at the specifics of
the winner-take-all dynamics in those
networks they don't really respect the
locality of the learning rules at least
that that's my understanding from
reading those papers so that's why we
figured we had to build this from
scratch plus ring works on the line of
defense depends on their online version
of k-means for generations I agree and
it just looked it and and they work
perfectly as we have well separated
clusters yes and they feel miserably but
Kimmy is also famous away any all of
those algorithms
an np-hard in the worst days so so it's
a it's not really clear I mean what do
you require right so their algorithm has
passed the online requirements but there
isn't a neural network with local
learning rules so that synapses are only
having an aunty have been derived from a
principled objective that doesn't exist
that did not exist in fact you are
correct and I'll go I will show you a
network that implements k-means online
in a biological plausible way but we
have to work for that ok so right so ok
so that's why I will ask you to bear
with me a little bit there is a little
bit of an unusual thinking about
clustering ok that we had to do so that
we generate an objective function that
then can lead to an online algorithm and
a neural network that has local learning
rules so it may look a little bit weird
in the beginning but it basically is
very close to k-means ok so what we have
is this two clouds of points we would
like to jet in the x1 x2 input space and
we would like to generate an output
which is this assignment indices that is
1 0 for red cluster and 0 1 for the blue
cost ok and we can do it very easily if
we think not in a centroid based way
like you usually do in k-means but in
similarity based way sort of like is
done in hierarchical clustering maybe
right so the two points are sufficiently
similar right you want to assign them to
the same output vector if the two points
are dissimilar you want to assign them
to different assignment indices which
happen to be orthogonal this can be
easily accomplished by simply
thresholding the input similarity right
if you think of input similarity is just
I mean the product of the stimuli
stimuli T and
then if you thresholded it the threshold
at alpha so that the output is 1 here
and 0 here you will get the desired
result
of course you would have to choose alpha
in a way that you know these points are
more similar than alpha and these points
are less similar than alpha but
basically that will achieve this goal
right because wood does you know what
does one mean for output similarity
since the norm of this vector has to be
1 it would have to be one of those two
and they would have to be aligned that
means you assign them to the same
cluster and zero means you end up in
different clusters because the
assignment indices are assignment
vectors are orthogonal is that question
[Music]
here is just an inner product right so
the goal of the reason why I had to redo
the clustering from the bottom up is
that we want to do it in a way that a
neural network could do with local
learning rules so we can do this kind of
similarity we cannot do a Gaussian
kernel for example I don't know how to
do it girl
this is so I mean your clustering needs
just one input but you said relativism
Authority faction is two inputs so it's
the one input in the similarity function
prototype or don't know this is applied
to a pair of inputs okay oh sorry
okay so what I should have said is let's
forget about the online requirement for
a second we will just derive the
objective function and then we'll do it
online and surprising as it is even
though the objective is derived in the
offline setting we will be able to come
up with an online algorithm okay so me
just one in the end once the system has
been trained I need you at one point in
the input space and then I can tell
isn't this or that class right well if I
refer to similarity I need two points in
order to calculate a similarity you are
correct and say these these two points
are close to each other all these are
far apart but there's something missing
you're absolutely correct and that's why
similarity thinks about it seems like a
very counterintuitive concept to use for
online clustering because you would need
to compare with every other stimulus in
fact right so huh exactly so so what we
are doing now is we just derive in the
objective not worrying about the online
for a second okay so imagine that all
the data is yes imagine imagine imagine
that you have all the data points right
so here we're just looking at two but we
will have all the data points and I just
want to derive an offline objective but
it will give you a clustering solution
so essentially you're making a point
that basically used in a medical plan
that you know Euclidean space only the
Euclidean space the Euclidean get since
globally doesn't make sense but locally
it makes a lot of sense so this is like
at the zero like all our approximation
to a geodesic yes if there are three or
more clusters and then if they're
dissimilar doesn't tell you very much
about where they should be put right
that's true in the hard clustering
they're just our thuggin all assignment
factor so it doesn't tell you much yes
okay so anyway so we want to threshold
so what kind of objective would give me
this kind of thresholding operation well
this is one okay so we're going to
maximize with respect to this assignment
indices whose norm is limited to one and
the components would have to be
non-negative this kind of expression
okay it's easy to verify that this
indeed does what we want to do if the
similarity is greater than alpha the
parentheses is positive and that means
to maximize this we choose the maximum
value of the inner product of wise which
is 1 of course because their norm is 1
but that means that the Y's are aligned
that means they belong to the same
cluster ok so that's this part if
similarity is less than alpha the
parentheses is negative we want to
choose or inner product of wise as low
as possible because the components are
no negative the best way to do it would
be to set them orthogonal that is
assigned to different clusters this is
some okay so this point these are just
two points and for two points it will
give you what we want the question is
will it work for the whole data set can
we just sum over T and tau that's not
easy question to answer because you see
the same YT is used in different pairs
of course so the different inner
products are actually not independent
and that's why it's not clear whether it
will work or not but it turns out that
it's pretty easy to prove a theorem that
if it so happens that the similarity
between all the pairs within the same
clusters are greater than alpha and
similarities of any two points from
different clusters are less than alpha
then indeed this solution will work so
you just set the positive elements of
the input similarity to the max the
negative elements to the min which is
orthogonal and outcomes the cluster
picture okay of course you would have to
choose
offered such alpha doesn't always exist
of course right but if we assume that
our data has well segregated clouds so
that distances between points from
different clouds are greater than
distance between any pair of points
within the same cloud then such alpha
exists and we can cluster by just
solving the subject ok so then we can go
from this you know cartoon of that fMRI
of IT with animate and inanimate objects
and cluster them have this two blocks of
ones and zeroes meaning that we assigned
all this stimuli to pets these are two
plants and this could be represented by
just two neurons because there are two
categories okay so that's pretty
straightforward what but but you know
k-means would do that too so why did we
do all that well we did all that because
with this kind of similar objective
function we can't actually solve this
problem in an online setting
even though as Lawrence point out you
need two examples to compare to compute
similarities and they are not available
at any given time step you only get
given are given one okay you can still
solve this problem and the answer
stylist suggests it has to do with
appear in appearance of the centroids
the way the centroids appear is oh by
the way I forgot to say one more thing
that this constraint on the amplitude on
the norm of Y is just here implemented
by Lagrange multipliers II to make this
biologically plausible but it's
basically the same problem okay so how
does this happen that we can just use
centroids this is the central line okay
so if you understand this you understand
similarity alignment basically the
tricky term here is this quadratic term
that has this different two different
axes and two different Y's and we can
transform it by bringing the sum over
tau inside
into this parentheses and calling that
sum w YX this immediately allows you to
perform optimization online because this
is such a big sum over many samples that
you have seen it doesn't really change
much from time step to time step and
whenever you get a new stimulus you can
use W Y X from the previous step you
don't really need to know the current Y
town so all you have to do is then to
optimize a quadratic function with
respect to Y T which is now the current
stimulus that is available to you there
is a non negativity constraint and there
is also this other term coming from
alpha and from Z that's why the actual
iteration looks a little bit more
complicated but basically what is
happening here is that you can solve
this optimization at every time step for
a given XT by a dynamics of neuronal
activity in reasonably looking
biologically looking neural network okay
because so this quadratic sorry this is
not even quadratic term this is a linear
term but a linear term sorry
results in just simply matrix vector
multiplication that is naturally
implemented if the DVD vector is
carrying of the components of X and then
the matrix W consists of synaptic
weights in this feed-forward connections
so that would compute W times X okay now
this term arises from a cross term
between y and z through the same kind of
trick and it has to do with the
normalization of the
assignment indices and it can be
implemented by representing Z by the
activity of one other neuron which is
natural viewed as inter neuron
inhibitory interneuron because of the
minus here okay and then the synaptic
weights from that inter neuron to the
principal neurons will be W Y Z's okay
which are also this correlations between
Y Z so it's hebbian and the threshold
here has to do with the summed past
activity B and parameter alpha which
sets the threshold on similarity okay so
then whenever a new stimulus arrives it
goes into this network each neuron
computes assumed produces a computes a
weighted sum of the feed-forward inputs
and feedback from the inhibitory
interneurons thresholds it which is near
what neurons love to do right and then
produces the output which also goes into
the inter neuron which does very similar
thing and and that whole activity
iterates okay so Z is the activity of
this inter neuron okay sorry I didn't
write it down
but Z would be just so so what you do
you just take a derivative of that with
respect to Z and you would get something
like ZT is is ZT plus gamma W Y is z y y
t minus theta I think there is a
threshold which comes from the which
comes from this term
in WC whack comes from and wzy is the
same kind of correlation that we had for
y-axis
just the architecture of the network how
many how many neuron principle neurons
we are signed so it also turns out that
you don't really have to be very
accurate you can produce an
overabundance you can build a network
with an over abundant number of neurons
and then they will get activated when
needed okay so you don't really have to
be very concerned about that there are
all kinds of regulations that you can do
to have that done automatically so you
draw this like season inhibitory
population but are you saying that W Y Z
and W XY are all positive or negative
right so because Y's and Z's have to be
non-negative any correlation of y&z
would be positive okay so then these
vectors this synapses have positive
weights and the reverse synapses which
are just the transpose of that matrix
come in with the minus in the dynamics
so this will be all negative the it
forward ones depend about what you
depend on what you assume about X if X
is also non-negative then they're all
non-negative so if you're concerned
about local learning and things such as
this does it concern you that for
example you have the transpose of the
weights being in some other place in
other words you have right so that no
that is not a major concern because
actually the rule is still heavy so you
don't have to you don't have to worry
about yeah you just run it and and it
all comes out fine in reality they may
not be exactly the same numerically but
yeah
okay and of course okay after the the
activity dynamics settles for each
stimulus presentation you have to update
the synaptic weights because there is a
new term in this sum the covariance has
to be updated by the additional term
okay and this learning rule was of
course local so you know biologically
plausible had been or at ante have been
synapses so that's basically the main
idea of similarity alignment so for a
certain family of objective functions
that are written in terms of similarity
this trick works like a charm and churns
out various biologically plausible
heaven and to have the network's and
when you require non negativity that
also corresponds to rectification in
neurons now I probably for this audience
I don't have to defend heavy on synapses
but let me just show you know one paper
that very clearly demonstrates this is
the case you know this is the
correlation between the activity of two
neurons and the cortex and this is a
synaptic weight between them okay so
that's of course as expected now the
next question okay now that we built
this network does it really do what we
wanted to do does it really cluster so
let's throw this easily kloss terrible
data set on that network of course you
have to realize that the network has not
been pre trained okay so you start with
some kind of virgin network with you
know initialize randomly or whatever and
you just keep throwing those data points
in it in an arbitrary order and it just
clusters the whole data so here we just
took the same but we do have regulations
that automatically choose the number of
course so if you choose if you start
with more in units yeah in clusters the
regularization will set some to zero
suppose you start with fewer there
there are both possibilities yes yeah we
start with fewer than they will merge
certain clusters so the split of the
cluster this is the interesting thing
well new clusters bomb that's right
there's a solution in the in the nail so
so because it's online the only thing
that we see is that you know initially
when you show the first data point first
neuron is activated then when you show
the second one if the second data point
is sufficiently close to the first then
that first neuron represents it if it's
not sufficiently close then another
neuron gets activated and this process
gets repeated it's alpha external
parameter yes alpha has to be set you
would have that's that's all you have to
you have to not with this simple not
with this not with this simple Network
that's true
and in my opinion this is what feedback
is for and yeah I don't think I'm very
regional about that but it may but I
have to warn you because this is an
oversimplified cartoon of the cortical
network in a minute I will show you what
we think is the most reasonable
biological implementation of this which
is the insect mushroom body which i
think is actually suits this very well
but I think cortex is a little bit more
complicated so ready to go on a limb how
strictly is your output orthogonalize
after this with the Y vectors so in this
case this is hard clustering so only one
neuron is nonzero in response to any
stimulus so it's always orthogonal okay
there is no structure now it is possible
to actually do soft clustering with it
it's very easy you just you add a l2
regularizer and Y to the objective
function and then you have multiple
neurons respond to each stimulus and
then the orthogonally will be lost and
that's what you can use to represent
hierarchical structures or manifolds
we'll get to that in the second part
so no original equations are there only
equations it appeared to me that the Y
vectors are sort of just chosen
appropriately for the X Factor's and
then this network structure someone
suggests that they why my cousin
actually computed from the X vectors
just choose no no so when I try to
motivate when I try to motivate the
objective function I said what why do we
want but the network has of course to
compute y on the fly for each stimulus
ok second questions of this w YX that
contains the principal all the data that
the network has seen yes we were
changing the statistic that's right
that's right this is a sufficient
statistics for this right but if there's
no insertion arity then you know right I
mean this is not this is not online yes
the clustering in the beginning is
somewhat wrong and that gets directed if
you don't get rid of the first examples
you keep this so yeah so it's very easy
to yeah it's very easy to build it for
getting into this so we have learning
rules with forgetting and then they can
track the changing statistics so that's
that's fine as long as your setting is
statistical rather than adversarial this
works just fine and in practice it works
all the time this recurrent Network have
to iterate over time yes yes so for each
stimulus presentation the network has to
iterate to compute wise and I realize
that this feature is somewhat on
biological so now we have derived
networks that do not have to iterate so
that is actually possible at least for
linear networks but I'm not talking
about this in the talk
it feels like maximum likelihood to me
if you had sort of exemplars that where
the distributions overlap then you're
gonna kind of cut them along the equal
probability yeah you will in fact the
reason this clusters is because it's not
that different from k-means which in
turn can be thought of you know what is
a Gaussian model expectation
maximization right so so that it is it
is related to what you said but let me
just show so everyone recognizes this as
a k-means objective function okay but
just by some algebra I can get rid of
the W's right because they're just
centroids of corresponding clusters and
I can get this expression where the
constraint again is this Lagrange
multiplier term and instead of this I
have this thing which look this is the
the cross term from the similarity in
white to similarity in X the only
difference from what I was just telling
you before is this normalization by the
sum of Y okay so it is possible to
rewrite a k-means objective function in
terms of this in this similarity looking
form and then you have a network with
biological learning rules that actually
performs clustering so it's not really
that surprising that this does as well
as k-means okay we seem to took a
right-angle turn from my question which
was oh then i didn't understand well
there there's a big faction of people
that think bayesian representations the
way they were brain works and so the in
depth
stumbling and to see how these the
complete overlapping distribution
algorithm all right so I don't I don't
have a slide on that but basically if
you do the following you just add to
this the term which is your plus trace
of Y transpose Y in the matrix notation
a ok
that kind of l2 regularization on top of
k-means will turn it into soft
clustering okay and then for each data
point you can activate multiple neurons
to a different rate you can associate
that or interpret this as probabilities
of a sign in that data point to a
particular cluster and that's actually
important right so that I think makes a
lot of sense I just didn't want to talk
about it yeah ok so we can do soft
k-means and because we could do
clustering we looked for a biological
network the your actual you know network
that could implement something like this
and what we found we think is the best
option that could be modeled by
clustering is operation of the mushroom
body and an insect so just a brief brief
review of olfactory system so most of
animals the way they smell is that they
have dedicated neurons whose receptors
are tuned to particular compounds and so
there are many of them but we have maybe
200 different ones and fly has 50 and
you know Mouse has a thousand so so
there's here I'm just showing just two
so there's a different kind of
dimensions of the factory space and
after the preliminary processing in the
insect it's called antennae lobe which
would be a factory bulb in the mammal
it's going to information is transmitted
to the part called the mushroom body
which has several characteristics that
makes us think that our prey model would
work just great there there is a huge
divergence from say 50 channels to 5000
there is only one
inhibitory interneuron for the whole set
of 5000 mushroom body canyon cells this
is surprising by itself but this is also
has been one of the problems with the
existing model of processing there
because if you apply for example sparse
dictionary learning yeah it's very hard
to do it with a single intern error but
for clustering of course you want just a
single inter neuron because what that
inter neuron does it just makes sure
that the norm of the assignment index
vector is doesn't exceed one that's the
only job the only constraint which is a
scalar constraint that it has to
implement and that's why it's a single
inter neuron so that's what we are
proposing and of course we can explain
then a lot of features right so it makes
sense that neurons are rectifiers right
because the assignment indexes are
non-negative right there is no sense of
having negative to belong to some
cluster with the negative weight right
even if you have probabilistic
assignment okay probabilities are
non-negative so actually that's why we
think neurons are rectifiers in general
because their present assignment indices
to different clusters as I mentioned we
can account for a single giant inter
neurons you get sparse over complete
representation of course because you
want to have many different clusters in
the olfactory space that could
correspond to different stimuli sparsity
arises from the competition and if you
have competition plus non negativity a
lot of the components have to be zeros
and of course this predicts non-random
connectivity which went against initial
experimental measurements in that system
but are now confirmed by connectomics
yeah I think there is an experiment
where they are bladed or shut down that
interneuron and they showed that
recognition of orders became worse I
don't remember is in BA maybe orders
orders odors yeah sorry is there
evidence that actually some clustering
coats of course on in this system I mean
there's these other models where you
actually trust this kind of you know
there's yeah so the the experiment that
suggests that it's more clustering than
compressive sensing is the fact that
there are neurons there are Kenyan cell
neurons that do not respond to pure
components of the mixture but respond to
the mixture right that wouldn't be the
case in a compressive sensing of you so
if that has been reported before by G
Laurent and others no no but but so what
I'm saying is that this neuron will not
respond to order a will not respond to
order B but it will respond to a plus B
and that looks to me more like
clustering than like compressive sensing
just two questions about the mushroom
buddy is a ordinance owner without a or
there are sortable in general this is
the only interneuron there it's called
giant intern yes so this circuit is
actually a somewhat of an
oversimplification but this one well
this part of the circuit is actually
pretty accurate there's more
complication going on with the output
when actions are decided and so on and
you know learning takes place but the
the input is is like that it is really
true as confirmed by connectomics
careful when you think about insects and
invertebrate runs because you might have
like a lot of the neurons are mono polar
and there's a cell body right but
there's very elaborate dendritic tree
and it's not necessarily true that this
ginger dick tree isn't like necessarily
in the you know it could be like
multiple little so so this is this is a
very good point and that possibility has
been considered and there has been a
debate in the community whether this
interneuron acts as one or these are
localized computations latest data that
i've heard about is that it has been
proven that it acts as one okay but
that's an experimental finding of course
i cannot claim that theoretical or order
mixtures have similar science scale
clusters or the cluster geometries of
the compact blobs or academic matters
they are probably manifolds but that's
why this talk has part two although
don't have that much time left okay all
right okay so now that's all I had to
say about simple clustering you there
anyone who have not seen the solution
okay so you're supposed to see young
woman or old woman even though the you
know this is the same the same image
right the same vector in the pixel
intensity space this of course is visual
illusion but it is here to emphasize the
point that two objects that very similar
in the pixel space could actually belong
to completely different classes and live
on different manifolds in the sky
dimensional space like animate and
inanimate and you know going back to
this illustration from County Carlow and
Cox right then the way to view the
visual system is that layer after layer
of visual processing is trying to
disentangle these manifolds without
destroying their internal structure so
that you can learn very easily from very
few examples by linear classification
and because you did not destroy the
structure of the manifolds you can
generalize right so that's one way to
think about object particular ization
and visual processing right and this is
of course what we really need to do
right clusters
you know belonging to animate and
inanimate in the pixel space they are
not well segregated they're probably
more like this of course the manifolds
don't really intersect they look
intersecting here because the projection
onto lower dimensional space still
they're highly entangled you have to
pull them apart well if you want to pull
apart those manifolds perhaps some kind
of manifold learning technique will work
which preserves neighborhood
relationships between nearby points but
tries to pull the manifolds apart and
there are many respectable methods in
you know manifold learning
that worked reasonably well but in my
view all of them lack biological
plausibility and the biggest problem
here is that there it's very difficult
to formulate them in the online setting
because most of these methods work in
the following way you compute you take
the whole data set you compute the
affinity matrix between all the stimuli
into a graph and then you perform a
spectral analysis of that graph and so
when the new point comes about you have
to recompute the whole graph doesn't
work in the online setting so what what
can we do well we thought well since we
built our network to preserve
neighborhood relationships maybe it can
do this manifold dissing tank weight so
we took our network and through this
cartoon of entangle manifolds right so
now these are two clusters there of
course not labeled
it's unsupervised but they cannot be
linearly classified right so what's
going to happen well first of all
nothing good is going to happen if you
use this original objective function
that I showed you because this describes
similarity in terms of just in a product
and if you put an origin here then this
points on the same axis will be
indistinguishable even though they
belong to different manifolds because
the inner products just depend on the
angle between the points so you have to
write it in terms of the equation
distances seems my may seem like a major
problem for neroli biologically
plausible networks but actually we know
how to build a neural networks that
process distance is not just
similarities so that's not a big deal
so we built a neural network that
optimizes this objective and outcome
this not very nice result because what
the network did they're just two neurons
and output and they just tear up the
tear off the data set
depending on the value of alpha
you can you know get more points
assigned to different clusters but
that's all they do they're not learning
manuals so we're we're invited to
pretend they never heard of support
vector machines like that well we want
something to be nearly plausible right
no there is a rectification well so the
high dimension part is right on if we
add more neurons if you don't just use
two neurons for two clusters but we
learn I think in this case we have to
use 40 neurons or so then miracle occurs
so those neurons actually learn
receptive fields that tile the two
manifolds okay and each neuron
represents only data points from one or
the other so this network can in fact
learn manifolds okay and because the the
neurons are either represented one
manifold out there in the next layer you
could just linearly classify it with
some supervision okay just to put this
data in a little bit more cut in the
format a little bit more familiar to
neuroscientist here is I just colored
the data points here by the neuron that
represents that data point that
activates in the response to that data
point I didn't have as many colors as
there are neurons okay so you see the
same color repeating but that's just an
artifact okay they do tile the manifold
with contiguous receptive fields of
course if you show this to
neuroscientists you immediately think of
place cells right
it's a few if you tell me your giant
engineering a little bit down so that
you can actually distribute its mass or
pacification what happens right so so
this doesn't have to be hard clustering
okay so depending on that l 2-norm
regularizer that i talked about you can
change the degree of sparsity and you
can make this clustering soft and you
can make receptive fields of different
neurons overlap in fact they do in this
realization you can see that where is it
like look here okay it clearly
overlapping no you don't okay but I will
get to it in a couple more slides okay
so so what what similarity alignment
seems to be able to do is not just a
cluster but to learn manifolds okay so
then we went on a theoretical
soul-searching trying to understand
what's going on and what helped me a lot
is knowing about the paper that was
published by Cho and Seoul in 2010 where
what they suggested is that neural
networks can be built to compute kernels
local kernels just like radial basis
functions except that they showed by
just performing exact mathematical
calculation that a single layer network
and okay they use F instead of Y but
it's a single layer network like ours
except that the number of units is
infinite the number of output units is
infinite and the weights are randomly
chosen from a Gaussian distribution they
not learned the randomly chosen from a
Gaussian distribution so this is like
random projections okay and the neurons
are active files with any of those
activation functions okay linear
rectifiers or other active fires so if
you have a network like this and you
present stimuli after stimuli the output
that Network gives can be thought of as
a kernel computation meaning that the
inner product of the output activities
for to stimuli T and T Prime depends on
the angle between those input vectors T
and T Prime
once they've been normalized theta in
this way so it's non-negative and it
goes to 0 of orthogonal vectors ok so
you get a significant kernel only the
two vectors are close to each other so
just like for Gaussian RBF kernel except
they called it our cosine kernel because
the exact they could compute this
integral exactly and show that it's
given by a closed form our cosine
expression ok and different shapes of a
kernel produced by different kinds of
nonlinearities so where does this kernel
come from ok it's very easy to
understand because to have a non zero in
a product you have to have components of
F that is neuron that is active with
response to different stimuli ok which
w's respond to a given stimuli because
of rectification to respond to stimulus
XT this w has to sit in this half circle
ok and to have a non zero activation in
response to stimulus T Prime this W has
to sit in the green half circle so the
number of w's that respond is given by
the area of the intersection and that
area of course decays on the angle so
that's the basic idea of cow
rectification leads to the locality in
the kernel sense okay
so what we did in this context is we got
rid of the requirement that you need an
infinite number of randomly generated
set up infinite number of neurons and
randomly generate synaptic weights by
learning synaptic weights through the
data so our kernel is not present from
the beginning the kernel is being
learned from the data as the data
arrives in the on-line way but the idea
of what's going on is is exactly like
choo and so described for random
projections because we can learn from
the data we don't need infinitely many
neurons we don't need to spend the whole
space ambient space of stimuli with
centroids we can only put the centroids
the W's only where the data lives so the
centroids will spend the same manifold
the same low dimensional manifold on
which the data lives that's why when
clay talked about computing embedding
for double use they form a low
dimensional space because they live in
the low dimensional manifold where data
lives ok all right so just one more
theoretical results of course you know
words are good and I appeal to this
random projection or result of chewing
soul but can we actually prove that our
network will really do that and in fact
we can we have to take advantage of
symmetry so for data set which uniformly
spends a circle for example as a
function of data we can solve an
optimization function exactly and show
that the receptive fields are bumped the
bumps the localized bumps like you saw
numerically this is possible because you
can write the problem in as convex
optimization using two positive matrices
I'm not going to go into that but some
of you will recognize the solution the
solution is that activation of each
neuron for the continuous representation
is simply a threshold cosine okay so
these would be the place fields of
individual neurons
indexed by their centroid file and we
could show that these are exactly
cosines amazingly this is the same math
as for the ring attractor it's exactly
the same math but the interpretation is
completely different in in in the ring
attractor these are individual neurons
that interact with each other here these
are data points that interact with each
other in the data space through this
computation okay okay it took it took so
it's actually under one single to derive
this so it took work but but there is
now an exact solution that shows that
this is what our network does it does
learn these kernels cosine kernels in a
data dependent way just as promised and
just to throw some eye candy you know we
can learn not just the place fields we
can start with place fields and based on
correlations for this synthetically
moving animal we can actually get grid
cells I mean that may not be that
surprising but we are doing it with the
network just that have been learning
rules a little bit more and why you guys
please cells
no so
green cells I cannot say much more other
thing about you know there was no non
negativity constraint this would be
simply PCA like linear model dimensional
radar amount of dimensional scaling so
you would get fourier harmonics once you
get non negativity you get something
slightly different but you keep the
periodicity so that's all I can say okay
all right and of course you know we
passed the whole thousand and few tests
we can learn the bore patches from
natural images but the big of course the
big prizes can we really stack those
layers to get from here to there we
don't know yet we think we can I want to
show one example where we have been
successful with stacking and that's an
example of this cartoon of entangle
manifolds using the spirals again the
network is completely unsupervised so it
doesn't see the red blue color it just
gets those data points and this is the
similarity matrix of the input once you
pass it through the first layer it
unfolds the manifolds okay and it sees
the two separate manifolds if you keep
stacking our network on top after the
sixth layer the two clusters actually
get pulled apart okay of course what you
need to do for that is you need to
reduce the number of neurons in the
representation as you go along right you
have to have this funnel that leads to
just two clustered neurons remember when
we try to apply a network with just two
neurons to the original data
nothing good healthy okay but when we
did a gradually layer after layer
reducing the number of neurons then this
clustering did happen of course we have
to go to such lengths only because we
require this to be completely
unsupervised if you allow just a little
bit of supervision you could cluster
after the first layer because there is
already one dimension along which red
and blue are
separated it's just not in one of the
top eigenvalues so you wouldn't get it
from spectral clustering but if you knew
if you had some supervised input you
could it does solve this but you have to
first compute an affinity graph via the
Gaussian kernel and I don't know how to
do this new early ok so this is our way
this is our workaround to do manifold
learning or kernel analysis in an online
biologically plausible way the cab in
networks okay I don't initially we
thought it just way to make things
biological now I'm starting to think
that there is maybe something
fundamentally useful to that kind of
approach where you compute the kernel on
the fly and the graph is being
recomputed in the online fashion rather
than doing it a priori as is done
conventionally but I would be happy to
talk about yeah it's an empirical visit
yeah you just ran it in it yeah yeah but
you didn't show that this actually will
always you know like theoretic I mean
what I'm saying is this is just running
it why don't you show that it I I think
we could do that I mean we did this
result that you know our first
theoretical result that actually shows
that we get this kernel is relatively
new so so I think we should be able
perhaps to extend it to that case but
yeah that's a good question
so to do something hard if you take six
layers to do something that's easy do
you think you'll have to get very deep
do image categorization no I don't think
so
I mean in in well okay I don't know what
it takes to do image categorization
because I don't think that the visual
system just repeats this one operation
that I just described which is
similarity alignment I think there is
something else right because you have to
learn in variances and stuff like that
so there are other things that need to
be done which we don't know how to do it
is not an abaya logical plausible way
right so then I don't know how many
layers you need but I want to point out
I mean this may be a little bit of a red
herring because you know that the real
computation is kind of done here
okay the manifolds are learned here all
the other layers are doing are fooling
are pulling those manifolds apart in a
very inefficient way if you get just a
little bit of feedback a little bit of a
supervised signal you could just do it
in a two layer Network very easily okay
where you just you know the first layer
computes this features and the second
layer is just a perceptron you're done
okay
but for completely unsupervised this is
what you have to do so I'm not sure it's
a really very very good model of
stacking in the visual system but that's
as far as we got so in this case it's
really just digital magical disconnected
components but I may want something
appreciative exactly exactly exactly so
so you would so if I'm talking about
model of the brain I would stop here
right and then I would do something else
at this stage and maybe then stack again
so just as a discussion points the
Daniela's in
Carlo they train these big before
networks with back prop and then compare
the internals of those before networks
to areas like before right makes Kennedy
explain garments and so in conversation
with Dan he pointed out that if the
object recognition portion of that task
in order to make those correspondences
with data is actually critical and if
you do the same the same analysis but
instead use a fee for network that was
trained as an autoencoder
that the auto encoding network does a
significantly worse job of explaining
the variation in the neural data well
but I I don't find that surprising right
because ok so you have two networks
right a one does natural object
categorization the other one does
artificial object categorization but
where do the categories come for their
official Network these are the same
categories that we perceive that are
presumably represented in IT so then you
have two networks where both the inputs
are the same and the targets are the
same so I brought it up because it
struck me that you may be honest
understand that you are motivating they
sort of stacked unsupervised structure
at least in some analogy - no no no no
not at all that's what why I was saying
this is just a way to show that we can
do this clustering we can pull the
manifolds apart but the biological
relevant part I think ends here
okay in the title is that you would
solve linked structure function and what
was the third moles of computation
computation I mean so I was somehow I
mean I when I went into the store never
somehow connect tommix and models and
also introduction sounded like that and
now it's more like a self-contained one
so where's the linkage to it okay yeah
so so so all this predictions of you
know double use I don't know what what's
good you know the predicted double use
that they're you know this that we can
compute the double use by actually
analyzing this data said there's
something that is can be tested and in
fact we are testing this in the
olfactory system where we have the full
conic tom but the problem is that we
don't have the true natural image data
set enough function right so we've tried
to do it with the data we have and we
have some preliminary education of
success but it was too too premature to
actually talk about it I felt but but
that's what we are doing
that's right so W can be measured by
connectomics but it can also be
predicted by measuring activity in that
circuit okay and then activity can also
be predicted the same way from W so the
this this theory allows you I don't know
which which are maybe this slide would
be the best sorry for
yeah so so this is this is a
computational objective that ties you to
what you want to do like cluster and
manifold learning the W's are expressed
in terms of activities so they can be
related to activities they can also be
measured through connectomics and of
course y's and x's are activities of
neurons that can be measured by
large-scale neuronal population
recordings like with calcium imaging for
example so this this ties together that
that's what I thanks for the question
actually yeah this ties together all
this three different levels of analysis
to experimental and one thread so
another place to look would be the
inputs to the cerebellum the mossy
fibers they go to this blue bear light
and then from there to the parallel
fibers and it's thought that there's
some kind of feature extraction yeah
and since this is feet forward whether
inhibition just like you've got in that
structure you might be able to have
another look at it but the other thing
is how was it scaling in terms of the
numbers right you know if giving it the
others so it said that there's ten
billion dollars 100 billion over in the
cerebellum
and most of those are granule cells
right so modeski LUP 200 billion you
think oh we don't know on a laptop we
can run up to you know a few thousands
but I don't see why not
all right I mean the only the only thing
that I find a little bit problematic for
such scaling is this iterative settling
of activity so we are trying to get rid
of it the whole brain right so so I in
this talk just for simplicity I only
talked about the similarity alignment
with a single inter neuron but we also
have other mathematical expressions that
give multiple inter neurons and those
multiple inter neurons may be
disconnected from each other or may
mutual inhibit each other as also
happens so actually that's that's my
final
which everything you can't incorporate
these balanced exhibition and inhibition
into your mother I'm sorry
so sir just just to answer so these are
different biological features that we
can capture in this by changing terms
and writing down a slightly different
computational objective so you know the
giant interneurons what I talked about
today but we can also do it's not yeah
so so we can also do multiple inter
neurons with nt have been rules so it's
all possible and yeah other kinds of
internet with other learning rules sorry
so the question was I mean it is it does
have to be all balanced I'm not sure it
will pass the the exact definition of a
balanced network in the sense of sample
insky and company but keep in mind that
this is not like a recurrent Network
that we are working with here it's
mostly a feed-forward network we are
recurrences on the feedback inhibition
so it's not it's not really the kind of
network from each balanced excitation
inhibition was right
you should the comment about not having
to kernel eyes to relate to manifold
embedding schemes in your updating rule
you have a W that appears in both terms
so so you you update the Y's and you
update the W's and then then those
doggies go back into the Y's so you get
this w squared and in the manifold
learning world there's a quadratic form
of that sort one distances and so it may
be the case that your scheme is working
there because you're implicitly forming
that nonlinear aspect the relevant
nonlinear aspect of
pearl by the two steps in your updating
we have to think about this it's not
immediately obvious to me maybe okay so
this is the most important slide there's
a people who are involved in this work
in different at different stages thank
you very much
missing young chichén who also should be
on that slide and it's my oversight can
you go back to the first time you should
first time is this the first time all
right yeah we have like a bunch of it of
like all of them yeah yeah so I'm
wondering like what happens if you like
put a data point that's not on one of
the spirals or like if you just you know
it's sampled the whole two-dimensional
space I mean would you just have like a
tile and with the neurologists tile this
whole space yeah so so depends where you
put it if you introduce small amount of
noise it will just work anyhow but if
you put it very far from it then you may
get a neuron that will represent just
that data point after its learned yeah
you train it with it after its learned
well then it's simple it's just the
projection you will try the to find the
the nearest the nearest centroids and
you will distribute activity among those
centroids every neuron here is really
hard clustering it just Voronoi in soft
clustering would be just like Maxim like
with like there's like just like a
circle and every question about the the
image coding example so how do you how
do you cut the image that is it
winner-take-all I mean is it just one
unit that gets to respond to the whole
image patch or do you somehow soften it
so that multiple units we just do you
mean when we learned Gabor patches oh
just like you did you know just patches
it's 12 by 12 patches neurons coding
that yeah is can only wonder on no no
this was okay actually to be honest this
is soft clustering but not just that
it was a network which we originally
called similarity matching which had
multiple inter neurons
so it's or maybe even know maybe even
direct connections yeah this college is
similarity between this learning rule
and goldy acts how is there some way to
oh yeah it's it's the same so if you
didn't have a non-linearity you know for
the linear one you could just we could
can also derive a network like this
and the learning rules are very close to
fold X I think four feet forward they're
exactly the same because these are just
oIA's rules for the he didn't have an
interneuron he had lateral connections
so for the lateral connections we get
slightly different learning rules our
normalization term is different but
remember that he did not derive his
learning rules
he just postulated them this was
heuristic and so it's nice that it
worked but you know it's very hard to
analyze the nature of the solutions ours
are derived from a principled objective
so we can actually see what the solution
will be so that that I think is the
advantage so this in some ways resembles
the self-organizing map yeah yeah with a
lot more I think rigor and theory behind
it but I think the dispirit it's similar
though yeah yeah I think I even yeah
yeah I think it's a it's a more
principled and biologically plausible
instance she she institution of social
enhancement
so so the key thing that came out was
that your update wore a history online
and be able to be rectified new year so
that would just automatically imply that
the objective function will be worth if
this came out from just doing gradient
descent I'm gonna do the function logic
function has to be quadratic with some
volatility constraint so so now if so if
so if you always think that neurons have
this ellipse then that means the only
class of objective function uses solve
is this is us all right but it's a very
big class we now have a huge family of
networks I mean even for clustering
right I mean we have this we have this
kind of objective and we have we have
this kind of objective right and this is
just like for classroom with the single
interneuron there are many many more
that we have straight so it's it's a
rich class so you see now if I want to
optimize some you know e to the minus X
or whatever then you know probably some
you're saying that biologically it's not
necessary to go okay so probably not
necessary but at this point in time
these are the only ones for which we can
make connection from the objective to
the online algorithm to the neural
network with local learning rules once
you write down a log or an exponential
which I I would love to write them down
it becomes much trickier and I'm not
sure how to do this at the moment so
that's that's the reason right so you
know that's why we use Euclidian
divergence rather than something else
like one if you shoot it just a little
bit the similarities zero right and so
how would you think about that so in the
right so you know they depends how much
data you have
if the data is sufficiently dense to you
know trace out a manifold in the pixel
intensity space then we will do just
fine well they're sufficiently close
ones that whose overlap is nonzero and
the network will learn that now whether
this is biological plausible well you
need to invoke some other ideas like
temporal correlation slow feature
analysis or whatever I don't know but
certainly for very high density of data
we can learn those manifolds
so okay so people have a break after the
break I think we will have after the
preggers discussion and it will be the
most energetic discussion that we'll
have at the entire lecture because that
was just one talk we are you know we are
not near 5 o clock so I please think a
little bit what are the points also the
bigger picture points we want to do this
us in and figure out you have felt now
almost 3/4 of the talks and so I think
it's now time to really think a little
bit bigger picture and then of course
dive into all the details where we
disagree but so so enjoy the coffee and
think a little bit about discussion
points too
we have some yeah you know that and so
we have lots of data now every talk is a
data point in the space of all possible
theories and the question is you know
how is that how we relate that 22 of the
34 say the cortex or cerebellum and it's
been you know theory theory has been
very good in biology and in in
neuroscience on the hole right there
there's the Derek cubes that we have but
it would be nice to try to integrate
across all of the different approaches
that we've heard you know it is is it
the case that there is a theory emerging
or more than one from all of them all
the data that's coming in that will come
in that we can